New York Times Reuters that's Wesley
Morris and Jenna where them take a
critical look at cultural issues in
their popular podcast it's called still
processing they've discussed a wide
range of subject since their first
episode last year from climate change to
Kanye West this week's episode was
especially poignant as they discussed
the violence in Charlottesville and
every time these things come up I get
down because it forces me to remember
how little people understand about the
history of this country that they want
to fight for willfully don't understand
Wesley Morris and general wertham join
us at the table to discuss welcome to
you both hey everybody
Jenna let's start with you a UVA
graduate mm-hmm and I'm wondering what
this was like for you to watch your
campus so unsettling so disturbing to
see the lot you were thinking yeah yeah
yeah I mean I've saw the photo of the
people with the tiki torches on the lawn
we walked down to graduate it was very
scary very unsettling tiki torches that
even the the Tiki company says listen we
have nothing to do with that these are
not our people these are not our beliefs
yeah yet you look at this and you say
you were not surprised I was surprised
to hear you say that why were you not
surprised well Charlotte suppose a town
that really has styled itself as sort of
a liberal liberal arts haven as a very
cultural safe space but the history of
Charlottesville is very dark and has
really predicated itself on the
exclusion discrimination and just you
know removal of black citizens
throughout its entire history and
Charlottesville has a chapter of the KKK
from back in the day but it was still
there so that history is still very
rooted so there are a lot of racial
tensions under the surface and feels now
that I was not surprised yeah what say I
thought you made an interesting
observation that when you look at the
tape it was White's against whites and
for many people I receive calls to say
who's who that struck you as well
yeah I mean the optics of these clashes
have tended to be in the history of this
country like optically very easy to
distinguish who's on which side it's
it's law enforcement turned against
black people and black people
confronting long what do you think about
the many of the civil rights clashes
like the sit-ins and
I mean this is a civil rights clash but
it's it primarily and like refreshingly
we would say involves white people and
this is going I mean that there's going
to give you any solution to this if
we're gonna get any closer to resolving
I actually do think that white people
have to play and it's like a majorly
significant part because we're not
talking about the passing of legislation
yes we're talking about trying to figure
out how to repress these dark forces or
dispel them entirely or to enlighten
them about what actually isn't happening
to them Michael Bennett talked about
some of us in football at least in the
protests that go on in the NFL and that
getting white players to join that would
he believes be helpful it's a big deal
mm-hmm it matters yeah I mean baseball
players are saying things yeah you know
I mean a few but I mean for anybody in
baseball they have to take a stand on
this it seems like a big deal Kevin
Durant saying he's not gonna go to the
White House for example another I mean
the sports we talk about sports players
because I think kids can relate to them
so many others can in this content
Norman Lear says he's not going to the
White House for the Kennedy Center it's
neither his comment at La vlog she's not
going to the White House either would it
have made a difference to you if
President Trump had strongly condemned
the protesters I think in his mind he
thinks he has done that Wesley hmm
yeah but he also equated them with the
white supremacists so I think that
they're the the equivocation is the
thing that is bothering everybody was
bothered by this it's also the degree to
which he doesn't seem to have the
capacity to empathize with anybody and
it's the degree and others have pointed
this out to the extent that to which
he's willing to double down on the
culture wars the more he feels
threatened do you sense that and and
what does that portend then occur thee
whose culture are we talking about the
American a culture mm-hmm I mean that's
a really interesting thing to look at
right because I think when people think
of American culture they sigh mean
there's a generations of people who
still think of it as white culture right
and so there's no aspect of American
culture that would involve black culture
that wouldn't also just be called black
culture so I think that there's a lot of
there's a lot of Ling
Ajay had to deal with and unpack I also
think that I mean I really honestly
think that having I mean every time
something like this happens with you we
have to have a real conversation about
that's not really it it's like there's
always a black person involved in one of
these dialogues and I actually think
that we should take a vacation from
having any magical conversations and
that why people talk it out it's also
it's important to note too it's like you
know I'm glad that white people went to
protest the protests right and to
protest the rally but it's easy to show
up and hold a sign it's a lot harder to
protest the repeal of Voting Rights Act
housing discrimination police brutality
like disproportionate police saying I
mean there's want to be active yes be
active don't put up a social media post
don't hold up a sign do something I mean
I think that's what I'm waiting to see
from white people and on a local level
too I mean a lot of the things that you
that are happening that you can actually
change you can change at at City Hall at
your State House and I think it can't
just be fighting white supremists in
person I think it has to be like
dismantling a system and our institution
of white supremacy and that's that runs
throughout the government Wesley Morris
general wertham that's it we're so sorry
you guys race conversation but you can
come back any time really good to see
you guys processing awesome still
processing is on the New York Times
website or wherever you get your podcast